Ich bin etwas später. Ich wollte normalerweise schon um eine halbe Stunde anfangen, aber
ich habe überlegt, ich fahre noch eine Runde Fahrrad hier auf meinem Smart Trainer. Obwohl
das Workout angeblich nur 45 Minuten dauern soll, habe ich irgendwie, keine Ahnung, eine
Stunde 15 oder so gebraucht. Wahrscheinlich, weil ich zwischendurch nicht mal konnte und
das Ding dann den Timer hat einfach nicht weiterlaufen lassen. Ich weiß es nicht genau.
Es hat auf jeden Fall länger gedauert, als es da gestanden hat. Das ist teilweise echt
brutal, ich sage euch Leute, wenn ihr nicht geübt seid und das Ding erzählt euch dann
von irgendwas 280 Watt über 4 Minuten zu fahren, dann denkt ihr euch auch nur Kegweight,
Alter. Ich weiß nicht, was du im Kopf hast. Also das ist so ein Ding, wo man sein Fahrrad
drauf stellen kann und die Kette dran macht. Das ist ein Wahoo Kegel. So ein Ding ist das,
guck. So ein Teil, genau so, da macht man sein Fahrrad dran und dann tritt man da in
die Kette. So sieht das dann aus. Naja, zumindest war das deutlich anstrengender. Ich muss sagen,
also seit ich angefangen habe, Fahrrad zu fahren und regelmäßig zu rennen, ich weiß
jetzt erst, die ganzen Weltrekorde und Profizahlen, die man manchmal so sieht, irgendwie auch
nur ansatzweise einzuschätzen, wie komplett außerhalb des Möglichen das für die meisten
Leute liegt. So krass, man. Ja, habe ich. Also ich habe einen Fiat 500e und den habe
ich tatsächlich ziemlich genau jetzt schon ein Jahr, ein bisschen über ein Jahr. Ich
habe den Ende August gekauft, 2022. Also sprich, habe ich den so ein Jahr, zwei Monate oder
so. Also ich würde den wieder kaufen. Das einzig doofe ist, was ich jetzt hatte, ist,
dass es irgendwie so ganz komische Geräusche macht an der Bremse links. Aber das ist wieder
weg. Ja, keine Ahnung. Also komisch, es ist super leise gewesen, aber nachdem ich auch weiß,
wie die CPU Auslastung von meinem PC ist anhand der Lüftergeschwindigkeit, höre ich auch komische
Geräusche an meinem Auto. Also insofern, naja, sehr weird champ. Ich bin echt ein bisschen im Arsch
jetzt. Zumindest, was ich gerade sagen wollte, es wird echt mal wieder Zeit für ein YouTube-Video,
gell? Kann das sein? Mal so auf Keckweight Basis. Also so langsam. Ich glaube, ich habe jetzt genau
zwei Monate kein YouTube-Video hochgeladen. Es wird echt mal wieder Zeit. Aber wie gesagt,
ich würde es wieder kaufen, das Auto. Jetzt kommen wieder manche, die sagen, oh Max, das
hört sich aber nicht überzeugend an. Keine Ahnung, wie ich es überzeugender sagen soll. Ja,
man kann ja immer reininterpretieren viel, wenn der Tag lang ist. Wenn man selbst eine Sache gut
findet, interpretiert man rein, oh ja, der Max findet es ganz toll. Wenn man es scheiße findet,
interpretiert man rein, oh, da hätte ich lieber was anderes gekauft. Aber ich kann euch nur sagen,
wie es ist. Also ich würde mir den wieder kaufen, den Fiat 500 G. Also ich weiß es jetzt erst richtig
einzuschätzen. Es ist so heftig. Wenn man zum Beispiel weiß, dass der Marathon-Weltrekord
einfach mal über 41 irgendwas Kilometer doppelt so schnell rennt, wie ich fünf Kilometer,
ist schon richtig krass. Und ich bin danach dead. Ich bin komplett im Arsch. Und er macht das einfach
über zwei Stunden für 42 Kilometer. Moin Patrick, 52 Monate. Massive Subscription hier. Und wie
laufen deine Kletterambitionen? Ich habe noch im Hinterkopf, dass du irgendwie angefangen hast,
Kletterstells zu machen. Ich war mal kurz, ich war mal kurz. Update für meine VM. VM-Update,
ist nie verkehrt. Ja, schick mal rüber. Was hältst du davon, als Software-Engineer in die
Schweiz zu gehen? Zum Beispiel Google die Verdienung. Naja, kommt darauf an, ob du so
flexibel bist und in die Schweiz willst. Also wenn du da nicht gebunden bist und sowas. Ja,
kannst du in den Chat schreiben. Aber keine G-Bait-Links posten, sonst müssen wir, Mod-Gists
müssen sich timeouten. Also keine Dick-Pics oder sowas jetzt. Ich gucke es mir eh in der
Vorschau erst an auf dem zweiten Bildschirm. Ja, einfach in Chat. Aspicon. Okay, das klingt,
das klingt tatsächlich nicht nach Typ-8. Stell dir vor, mit deinem Job kannst du wirklich was
in dieser Welt bewegen. Boah, das ist immer so riesengroße, große Worte immer, ja. Ich war mal
kurz, ich war mal kurz. Update von meiner VM. Muss mal sein. Ja. Und ohne Scheiß, wenn ich
Probleme habe, muss das jetzt gerade noch fertig los werden. Wenn ich Probleme habe, ja, auf meinem
Trainer hier daheim über vier Minuten lang 280 Watt zu treten, das kriege ich nicht, das kriege ich
nicht. Also das kriege ich einmal hin, dann kann ich eigentlich absteigen und für den Tag muss ich
mich nicht mehr draufsetzen. Und ich dann irgendwie sehe, dass du irgendwelche Profis hast, die mit
irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 450 Watt den Berg hoch ballern. Da denkst du dir auch, wie geht das
eigentlich, Mann? Das ist super krass, Alter. Ich konnte das vorher überhaupt nicht einschätzen,
jetzt auch nicht richtig, aber es ist so heftig, was die da teilweise abziehen, ja. Wäre ja ein
bisschen sinnverfehlt, ja. By the way, du bist ja schon alt, hast du irgendeinen Altersversorgerplan,
wie? Ich habe einen ETF, ja. Also was ist ein? Ist ja nicht so, als hätte man, also es besteht ja aus
mehreren Sachen, aber auch nur, weil ich zu faul bin, irgendwie was anderes zu machen. Ich habe
einen, Moment, wo ist mein Handy? Wo ist mein Handy? Sekunde, Sekunde, ich kann es euch sagen,
ich habe einen. Die Stonks sind aber nicht so gut gerade, deswegen will ich da gar nicht reingucken.
Dankeschön für den Sub, aber ohne Miss, Leute, es bringt echt was. Also ich merke,
dass ich habe, Face not recognized, Leute, Face leak fürs Handy. Heute gab es Stonks,
heute ging es hoch wieder ein bisschen. Oh, tatsächlich, es ist tatsächlich wieder minimal
im Plus, nachdem es übelst runtergegangen ist den letzten Monat. Ja, ich sehe es gerade. Es
ist tatsächlich ein bisschen hochgegangen. Ja, also ich habe, ich habe Stonks. Da bezahle ich
ab und zu mal was ein, in der Hoffnung, dass es dann in ein paar Jahren noch mehr ist.
Arzi, dankeschön für den Sub und Patrick, danke für den Sub und falls ihr irgendwas vergessen habt,
sorry, Leute. Guck mal hier, kommt, Leute, vier Minuten für einen Sub, das kriegen wir noch auf
die Reihe. Dann freue ich mich und Besos kann noch mal ins Weltall fliegen, das ist allen geholfen.
Und ihr kriegt Porgas Emotes im Chat, wo ich übrigens noch vier verschiedene,
dankeschön, Danny, C.R.S., Porg-Subscription-Liste, das hatten wir schon eine Weile nicht mehr. Also
heute ging es wirklich hoch, ja, ich habe es auch gerade gesehen. Ja, wie gesagt, also das mache ich.
So, ich schmeiße jetzt mal die Updates an von der FM und dann gucken wir uns die Stellenanzeige
an von Jack Jackson. Muss ich mal vorstellen, ich packe maximal über ein paar Minuten auf meinem
hier Fahrrad, packe ich maximal für ein paar Minuten so 2,5 Watt pro Kilogramm. Das kann
ich aber jetzt auch keine Stunde durchfahren oder so. Also vielleicht, vielleicht, vielleicht fünf
Minuten, da bin ich nett. Und die bei der Tour de France ballern, gut, die wiegen auch nur die
Hälfte von mir, aber trotzdem, die bei der Tour de France ballern mit 6,5 Watt das Kilogramm den
Bärkorallen. Das ist komplett unmenschlich, das kann man... Ja, ey, Leute, ich könnte alles Doping
der Welt fressen und ich würde nicht 3 Watt das Kilogramm schaffen. Ihr könntet mich, ihr könntet
mich alles, Pillen, Spritzen, Zäpfchen, was gibt es noch zum Inhalieren, Augentropfen, alles, das
wird nix helfen. Plus irgendwie noch alle, alle, alle zwei Minuten so eine Adrenalinspritze oder so,
selbst das wird nicht reichen bei mir. Gewicht geliegen, ja Gewicht müssen wir nicht liegen,
Gewicht habe ich schon oft genug geliegt. Also aktuelles Gewicht, na ich weiß es nicht ganz
aktuell, ich habe mich letztens drauf gestellt, da hatte ich aber Hose, Socken, T-Shirt, alles an,
da waren es 93, aber normalerweise ist es morgens so um die 91. Man sollte sich ja immer ein bisschen
vergleichbar wiegen, so nach dem Motto morgens in Unterhose oder morgens nackig oder irgendwie so,
sonst ist das schlecht, schlecht vergleichbar. Also so um die 90 ist es gerade. Angefangen vor
eineinhalb Jahren habe ich mal mit 108,5, Körpergröße 174, also immer noch Massive Pipo Fett, aber nicht
mehr ganz so schlimm wie vor eineinhalb Jahren. Dafür muss ich sagen, durch das Regel, also erst
mal habe ich durch regelmäßig Bewegen deutlich schneller abgenommen als durch wenige Essen. Wenige
Essen, ihr kennt mich, wenige Essen ist sehr schwierig. Ich fresse halt immer gerne, wenn es
schmeckt so viel. Also das einzige, was bei mir wirklich geholfen hat zum Abnehmen, ist vielleicht
ein bisschen weniger essen, aber eigentlich auch nicht so wirklich. Vielleicht ein bisschen gesünder
essen, aber auch nicht so wirklich. Vielleicht ganz, ganz, ganz minimal als Seiteneffekt. Das
einzige, was bei mir wirklich geholfen hat, ist täglich eineinhalb Stunden bewegen. Ohne Scheiß,
das ist das einzige, was bei mir geholfen hat. Und jetzt seit irgendwie so zweieinhalb Monaten,
seitdem ich regelmäßig Rennen gehe und Fahrrad fahren, hat sich am Gewicht ein bisschen was getan,
sagen wir mal so eineinhalb Kilo vielleicht, ja. Aber ich bin viel fitter insgesamt, das merke ich
auch. Also ich komme eigentlich bei alltäglichen Sachen mittlerweile Null außer Puste. Also ich
kann echt nur empfehlen, ab und zu mal ein bisschen bewegen ist wirklich nicht so schlecht.
Das ist quasi der Giga-Chat-Move. Was hast du für ein Fahrrad? Die Wattmesser sind auch
nicht billig. Ich habe ein kaputtes Fahrrad, weil ich umgefahren wurde vor zwei Wochen am
Samstag. Aber für einen Heimtrainer tut das noch und der Heimtrainer hat halt auch so eine
Leistungsmessung drin. 7LQRS, danke schön für den Sub. Ja, vorletzten Samstag hat mich ein Auto
auf dem Fahrradweg umgefahren. Not-So-Pog, Mini-Pog quasi. Oder was ist das Gegenteil?
MonkaS eher. MonkaSteer. MonkaSteer ist, glaube ich, das Richtige. Richtig, deswegen habe ich
mir da gar keine so viele Gedanken zu gemacht. Wenn ich jetzt am trainieren bin und nicht so
sehr abnehme, aber dafür ein paar Muskeln kriege an den Stellen, die zu den Sportarten passen,
ist mir das auch mehr als recht. Also wo ich das wirklich extrem gemerkt habe, ist,
als ich angefangen habe zu rennen, eher so ungefähr alle zwei Tage. Also wenn ich schnell
renne, dann nur fünf Kilometer, ansonsten ist meine Standardrunde so 6,2 Kilometer. Und also
was ich extrem gemerkt habe, die ersten Male, wo ich gelaufen bin, also die ersten eineinhalb,
zwei Wochen. Alter, Leute. Also bei den ersten Malen haben mir einfach nur die Beine und die
Waden wehgetan. Das war aber gar nicht so schlimm, das ging dann nach ein, zwei Tagen wieder weg.
Das war so ganz am Anfang, so die ersten drei, vier Mal rennen. Aber was dann war, und das hat
tatsächlich bestimmt fast einen Monat gedauert, bis sich das jetzt ein bisschen gelegt hat,
ist, mir hat das Schienbein übertrieben wehgetan. Immer den Tag, nachdem ich gerennt bin. Aber ich
meine, mein Schienbein ist einfach nicht die Belastung gewöhnt von 90 Kilo, was dann mal so
drauf rammt, so im Sekundentakt. Ja, ich auch nicht, ich auch nicht. Aber gleich kommen wir
zu Stellenanzeigen. Ich will nur mal gucken, ob meine Frau immer richtig geupdatet hat.
Ja, nix. Ganz ehrlich, ich kenne das, ich habe das letzte, du meinst dieses Diabetes-Medikament,
ja nix. Ganz ehrlich, das Beste, was man machen kann, ist sich mehr bewegen. Das ist nicht nur
gut fürs Abnehmen, weil Abnehmen alleine ist, denke ich mal, nur die halbe Miete. Du hast die
ganzen positiven Nebeneffekte nicht, wenn du nicht durch ein bisschen mehr Bewegen abnimmst.
Du hast weiterhin Rückenprobleme, du hast weiterhin Kopfschmerzen, Nacken, sonst was,
Beine, Hintern. Du bist außer Puste, vielleicht ein bisschen weniger außer Puste, weil du ein
bisschen weniger wiegst. Aber das, also meiner Ansicht nach, und das ist auch das Einzige,
was überhaupt je bei mir geholfen hat, und das funktioniert echt ganz gut, es ist gar nicht so
viel weniger essen oder sonst was, sondern einfach schlicht und ergreifend mehr bewegen. So doof
es klingt, ich wusste das, ich wusste das, ich, das ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich das nicht wusste,
das weiß, das weiß jeder, ja. Aber, also der erste Schritt ist erstmal, es zu realisieren, okay,
aber das weiß eigentlich jeder. Der zweite Schritt ist tatsächlich, dass das zu machen. Und man muss
es gar nicht übertreiben. 45 Minuten mal am Tag ein bisschen spazieren gehen, ist so viel besser
als einfach nur hocken. Ich weiß, ich höre mich an, so wie mein Opa, der mir das früher immer
erzählt. Das ist einfach ein Riesenunterschied. Wie hast du damals, als noch jung warst, neue
IT-Themen gelernt? Gibt es da viele Möglichkeiten, wie du dir Bücher... Also ich, also ich habe
tatsächlich, ich habe tatsächlich noch relativ viele Bücher gelesen, gerade wenn es um Programmiersprachen
und sowas ging, so für Ruby, für C Sharp damals, gibt es übrigens immer noch ein ziemlich gutes,
kostenloses Einstiegsbuch. Ja, als GIT neu war, hatte ich, habe ich mir auch so ein größeres Buch,
aber jetzt habe ich tatsächlich noch wirklich, wie nennt man das, Hardcover, ne, wie heißt das,
so ein richtig echtes Buch halt gekauft. Mittlerweile lese ich auch ganz gerne noch,
nennen wir es mal Fachliteratur, aber dann nur noch als E-Book. Ey, es hat jeder, es hat jeder,
das ist für mich keine großartige Motivation gewesen. Also ich habe nie, bis du das jetzt
geschrieben hast, habe ich nicht daran gedacht, so nach dem Motto, Max, mach mal krasse, krasse
Training-Action, dass du mehr Mädels abchecken kannst. Bis zu deinem, das war überhaupt nicht,
mir ging es wirklich einzig und allein darum und ich glaube, das ist auch, ich meine, hey,
jeden, jeden, was ihn motiviert, ja, wenn es jetzt einen motiviert, so nach dem Motto, ich bewege mich
mehr, weil ich dann fett die Weiber abchecken kann, alles gut, jeder, was ihn so motiviert,
wie heißt das, das sage ich gleich, aber ich glaube, das Beste ist, wenn man realisiert,
dass das unmittelbar und dass das so krass ist, hätte ich auch nicht gedacht, dass man unmittelbar
riesen Vorteile dadurch hat. Du hast instant, fast, also wenn du anfängst, ein paar Tage,
vielleicht ein, zwei Wochen gemacht hast, du hast instants, instant, so keine Kopfschmerzen mehr,
nix im Rücken mehr, viel, viel weniger irgendwelche Verspannungen, die ein paar Tage dauern.
Nix am Bein, du kannst dich besser konzentrieren, dein Hirn funktioniert besser, das merkst du gerade
die ersten ein, zwei Wochen, weil der Unterschied so krass ist, mittlerweile gewöhnt man sich ja
dann, ja und ja, das kann man auch machen. Leute, das ist eines der Punkte, was mich auch motiviert,
ich kann jetzt übelst viel fressen, wenn es was gibt, was schmeckt und ich weiß, wenn ich nachher
eine Stunde Fahrrad fahren gehe oder heute morgen mal eine Runde Rennen war, dann ist das vielleicht
nicht ganz weg dadurch, aber fast weg und durch das, was es noch ein bisschen so an Nachwirkungen
hat für den Tag, ist es eigentlich weg. Also im Prinzip, es hat, das kann auch motivieren,
man kann mehr fressen, ja und aber eins, aber eins muss man sagen, du musst auch mehr fressen,
weil du hast Hunger, as fuck. Ich, also ohne Mist, seit ich angefangen habe, mich mehr zu
bewegen jetzt, ich habe immer, also ich meine, ich hatte vorher schon immer Hunger, ja, ich konnte
früher, ich konnte immer was füttern, aber Leute, ich könnte echt gerade den ganzen Tag fressen,
aber wo kriegt man die Zeit her, wenn man so voll arbeitet, auch wenn man sieben Tage die Woche hat,
naja, also ich, also ich mache das so. Mein Ziel ist, wobei ich das so nicht weiß, ob das langfristig
die beste Planung ist, also bis, bevor ich angefangen habe mit Fahrrad fahren, bin ich
einfach jeden Tag, jeden zweiten Tag Rennen gegangen. Unabhängig davon, ob mir das Schienbein wehgetan
oder nicht, ich habe einfach gesagt, auf geht's und ich konnte mich auch bei Scheißwetter und so
dazu motivieren. Jetzt und, also gut, wie ich das gemacht habe, war eigentlich ganz einfach,
jeden zweiten Tag musste ich viel überlegen, du weißt, gestern war es ja nicht, heute musst du
wieder und ich habe das einfach morgens gemacht, morgens ist auf der Arbeit noch nix los und da
gehe ich so um, wann gehe ich denn immer, so 7 Uhr, mal überlegen, dass ich jetzt kein Mist erzähle,
ja, so 7 Uhr 40 oder so, 7 Uhr, ne, ne, eigentlich sogar noch ein bisschen früher, 7 Uhr 30 vielleicht,
7 Uhr 30 bis, bis 8 Uhr 20, 8 Uhr 30, je nachdem, ja und je nachdem, wie das getimt ist und je nach
Woche ist das gar nicht so wild, weil, wenn es auf Montag fällt, dann ist es kein Arbeitstag,
dann ist Dienstag, dann ist Mittwoch und Freitag, sind nur zwei Arbeitstage und die, die Zeit passt
mal, zumal die Zeit doppelt und dreifach wieder kriegen, ich habe vorhin, ohne einzustechen,
beispielsweise noch auf, noch, noch 40 Minuten was auf der Arbeit gemacht, weil unsere tolle
Blockchain Sachen wieder nicht richtig synchronisiert haben, ja und das geht, wenn du das morgens machst,
ist eigentlich kein Ding, das geht natürlich nur, wenn man Homeoffice, wenn man Homeoffice machen
kann, na, auch vor der Arbeit, wenn ich mit dem Zug auf die Arbeit müsste, hätte ich da auch keinen
Bock drauf, was, was ist das, hast du Progressstream gemacht oder wie, nice, oh jetzt sieht es ja,
jetzt sieht es ja richtig advanced aus langsam, Web 5.0, welches Rad hast du jetzt eigentlich geholt,
das hier, aber das ist kaputt, wie gesagt, ich wurde umgefahren auf dem Fahrradweg letzten,
vorletzten Samstag, Doomsweb, danke für den Sub, ja und jetzt, und also mein Ziel ist, um das jetzt
mal abzuschließen und zu den eigentlichen Stellenanzeigen zu kommen, sonst wird das heute
nämlich wieder nix, mein Ziel ist jetzt, und ich bin mir noch nicht so ganz sicher, dass ich mein
Schienenbein ein bisschen, ein bisschen schonen kann, ja, dass ich renne, Fahrrad fahre, Pause
mache und dann erst, also quasi, dass ich, dass ich zwei Tage Pause zwischen dem Rennen habe und
ein Tag komplett Pause mache und ein Tag Fahrrad fahre, so, das ist so, das ist so mein Plan jetzt, ja, Fahrrad
fahren kann auch auf dem Trainer daheim sein, wenn scheiß Wetter ist, also quasi rennen, Fahrrad fahren,
Pause, rennen, Fahrrad fahren, Pause, rennen, Fahrrad fahren, Pause, also das ist jetzt so, das ist das, was ich mir so
überlegt habe, was ich ganz gut, ganz gut integrierten kann in mein Daily Business, ja, mal gucken, was so alles kommt,
ja, Leute, wenn ihr Stellenanzeigen habt, die ich mir angucken soll, schickt her, ansonsten suche ich jetzt gleich auch mal,
da gibt es ja immer abenteuerliche Sachen, weißt du, wie man an die, Edu, Adobe, keine Ahnung, ich habe absolut
keine Ahnung, benutze ich nicht, womit hast du die VmWare, womit hast du die VmWare laufen, VmWare, VmWare habe ich
laufen, guck da, ja, vor allem, mir persönlich auch deutlich lieber als, als Virtualbox, so, dann gucken wir uns das hier doch
jetzt mal an, Entwicklungswinner vor allem, ja, regelmäßig hier im Stream auch, also eigentlich nur exklusiv, ich, ich, ich
entwickle unter Windows eigentlich gar nichts mehr, ich glaube, ich habe, egal was es ist, von Web Backend bis
Frontend bis CLI-Tools, C-Sharp, Go, Ruby, Bash-Skripts, Python, eigentlich exklusiv alles nur in der VR-Motorlinux, ja, wie gesagt,
ich, ich lese immer noch ganz gerne E-Books, wenn es um Technik-Sachen geht, wenn es gute gibt zu dem überliegenden Thema,
zum Beispiel eines der besten Bücher, die ich kenne, die ich gelesen habe zum Thema .NET C-Sharp-Entwicklung, ich habe vergessen,
wie es genau heißt, das ist das, das ist das, wo, wo auch John Skeet dran beteiligt war, glaube ich, der, der Stack-Over-Flow C-Sharp-Master,
oh, wie hieß das, wie hieß das denn, das, das, das war so C-Sharp-Best-Practice-Sachen, da habe ich, da habe ich viel draus gelernt,
was, war es C-Sharp-In-Depth, ne, ich weiß es nicht mehr, das war echt gut, das würde ich mir auch wieder als E-Book holen,
also man kann aus Büchern, wenn es halt Gescheite für das jeweilige Themengebiet gibt, finde ich, teilweise einfacher lernen als mit Tutorials und sonst was,
weil es eben gut strukturiert ist und durchdacht, ja, da ist ein bisschen mehr Qualitätssicherung dahinter, so ein, so ein YouTube-Tutorial,
wenn ich das sehe, dass, dass es teilweise Leute gibt auf YouTube, die machen dann irgendwie einen 53 Stunden XYZ-Kurs und das meiste davon ist,
wie downloade ich mir Visual Studio Code, wie downloade ich das, wie mache ich hier, wie installiere ich das, so Content 10 Stunden und 53 Stunden, das ist halt einfach unsinnig, ja,
ich hatte mir, ich hatte mir mal vor der ganzen, vor der ganzen längeren Zeit mal einen Kubernetes-Kurs auf Udemy gekauft, vor, keine Ahnung, 4 Jahren oder so,
einen, einen Terraform, einen, irgendwie einen Azure-Terraform-Kubernetes-wie-auch-immer-Rundumschlag-Kurs
und der war so schlecht, der war an den Teilen, wo man es wissen wollte, zu oberflächlich und dort, wo es nicht interessiert hat, super ausführlich, ja,
der hat eine halbe Stunde erklärt, wie du irgendwelche CLI-Tools installierst und wo du die herkriegst und was es ist,
aber wie man, wie man damit advancede Sachen macht oder interessante Sachen, die man macht, hat er mir wiederum nicht richtig gezeigt, also voll für den Arsch,
also es gibt sicherlich gute Udemy-Kurse, aber, naja, der war nicht gut, E-Books, wenn es dazu welche gibt, ist nicht verkehrt,
wie das kostenlose C-Sharp-Buch heißt, das kann ich dir sagen, hat eben auch einer gefragt, Gali, Leo, OpenBook, C-Sharp,
ähm, das hier, das ist zwar, das ist zwar 2012, das ist aber nicht schlimm, es reicht, also du kannst im Prinzip bis, bis hier, inklusive 16,
den Rest kannst du vergessen, aber die Basics sind immer noch ganz, sind immer noch recht relevant,
natürlich fehlen da viele moderne Konzepte, aber zum Einstieg ist es gar nicht so schlecht, weil es nicht 100.000 neue Sachen behandelt,
sondern wirklich nur die Basics, finde ich ganz gut, nee, Laufbahn anschreibt sich will ich nicht,
ich hab, ich hab den Trainer mit dem Fahrrad hinter mir stehen, so halb hochgeschoben an der Wand, dass das Fahrrad sich so viel Platz wegnimmt, aber,
da muss man ein bisschen aufpassen, bei Scheibenbremsen, dass man das Fahrrad nicht auf den Kopf stellt,
wobei, eigentlich ist es egal, ich behalte das eh nur an dem Trainer, da brauche ich keine Bremsen, so,
ist ja, was passiert bei dem Unfall, ja, mir hat ein paar Tage, also ich hab ein bisschen, ein bisschen abgeschürft am Arm, am Bein,
mir hat ein paar Tage die Hüfte und der Arm weh getan, aber bis jetzt, jetzt ist eigentlich alles, alles wieder gut,
ist die Anzeige raus, nee, die Anzeige ist nicht raus, aber ich hab den, ich hab einen Anwalt beauftragt, der sich da um die Versicherungssachen kümmert,
ich hab vom Gutachter schon was, der sagt, mein Fahrrad hat einen Restwert von irgendwie 70 Euro oder so, einmal 3500 gekostet,
und der Anwalt hat auch schon an die Versicherung geschrieben, die sollen letztendlich mal bezahlen, so,
nein, mach ich nicht, es sieht richtig nice aus, ne, gerade mit den neuen Icons hier neben, ah ja,
Pork, Pork Icons, sind das AI generierte Thumbnails, jetzt wird's, jetzt wird's aber wirklich langsam, ich glaube,
ich glaube, wir müssen das langsam mal vermarkten, dieses Ding, oder, ja, wie gesagt, wie gesagt, alles in der VM,
ich müsste mal updaten, ja, weil es jetzt ja angeblich auch Xbox gibt, die Daten sind in der VM,
oh, die kann man ja einfach rauskopieren, ja, mach mal, da kann ich, wenn die gut ist, sag ich nichts,
wenn die gut ist, dann ist es Schleichwerbung, okay, wenn die schlecht ist, dann flame ich euch,
dann ist es wahrscheinlich das Gegenteil, klar, warum nicht, wenn das irgendwie tut, ich hab eh nicht vor,
bis zur Rente zu arbeiten, und ich denke mal, dass das auch theoretisch ganz gut möglich ist,
ich meine, ich verdiene nicht schlecht, ich hab ein bisschen Kohle auf der hohen Kante, ich hab ein Haus,
da geht was, ich hab noch Einnahmen von Twitch, YouTube und anderem Zeug, ja, aber aktuell sind vier Tage Woche
perfekt für mich, so, hast du, nein, hab ich nicht, darfst du, darfst du, darfst du, da müssen wir keine Umfrage machen,
darfst du, als Endeavor-OS-Nutzer darfst du dich Arch-User nennen und uns auch immer drauf hinweisen,
dass du Arch, by the way, ust, aber als Manjaro-User nicht, die Stonks liefen heute anscheinend gut,
davor nicht, da gibt's nicht viel zu zeigen, ein ETF, fertig, so, auf geht's, dann gucken wir uns das nochmal an,
meine Augen, meine Augen, also bei mir sammeln alle, die Dark Themes anbieten, für, Moment, das ist gar nicht das Richtige,
die Dark Themes anbieten für ihre Bewerbung schon mal Pluspunkte, sowas zum Beispiel, guck mal, ah, ne, die auch nicht,
Moment, ist das, hatten die den Dark Theme, ne, wär auch zu einfach, ey, du darfst Manjaro, by the way, sagen,
damit machst du dich aber lächerlich, weil das keiner sagt, da outest du dich als Manjaro-Noob,
der Gelnhausen-Dude, Union-Investment, da kenn ich sogar ein paar Leute, die da arbeiten, so, dann gucken wir uns das doch mal an,
let's go, was haben wir denn hier, Aspicon, ist der Jackson Jack noch am Start, oder hab ich zu lange gebraucht,
dass der die Stellenanzeige, ah, du bist noch da, okay, was für ein ETF, einen, den 0815-ETF, den jeder hat,
einen, genau, Vanguard, FTSE, All World, UCITS, ETF, USD, Accumulating, so, also, Linux-Systemadministrator,
ich verkneif mir meinen Standard-Joke, ihr kennt ihn ja alle schon, unbefristete Festanstellung, Vollzeit, 5 Tage, 40 Stunden, unflexibel,
okay, deutsch fließend, englisch gut, festgehalten, zu lang, Benefits, Reisetätigkeit, nein, das ist schon mal top,
ich hab eh keinen Bock drauf, PwC, oh, nee, auf die hätte ich gar keinen Bock, wir glauben an dich, das klingt, das klingt nicht schlecht,
können wir gleich schauen, also, jetzt gucken wir uns aber erstmal das an, also, was haben wir denn hier, das ist Aspicon,
was macht denn Aspicon, haben oben schon mal, ah, Suse, MonkaS, alter, Suse, oh, Windows, ja gut, da haben sie die zwei Sachen schon mal richtig zusammengeschrieben,
Suse und Windows-Server, das ist nochmal um die Leute abzuschrecken, ja, AWS, Azure, oh, Oracle Cloud, Docker, Helm, das ist auch random einfach irgendwie zusammengewürfelt,
oder, was da oben in der, na gut, okay, wer ist denn das überhaupt, ein Obstkorb, ja, das ist natürlich schon das Qualitätskriterium heutzutage,
okay, irgendeine Beratungsbude, oder, also, du trägst Verantwortung für Server, Storage, Virtualisierung unter zwei Komponenten in komplexen Linux-Systemen,
das klingt ziemlich passend zu einem Linux-System-Administrator, ist ja schon mal was, wenn der Titel der Stellenanzeige was mit dem Inhalt zu tun hat,
dann muss man ja schon teilweise echt schon begeistert sein, du entwickelst Automatismen für Prozesse, wie zum Beispiel das Ausrollen, Konfigurieren von Software oder das Updaten und Patchen von Infrastruktur,
ja, ich finde diese Umschreibung ja blöd, du entwickelst, okay, für Prozesse, sollen sie einfach schreiben, du automatisierst unsere Infrastruktur oder irgendwie, du nutzt moderne, ach, was weiß ich,
IAC-Tools, irgendwie so ein bisschen, das ist immer dieses Business-Speak, finde ich da irgendwie immer nervig drin, aber ey, das ist keine schlechte Stellenanzeige, ja, das machen alle so,
aber ich finde es immer deutlich sympathischer, wenn das einfach auf technischer Ebene, dass du weißt, okay, oder zumindest, derjenige, der da sucht, ist auch derjenige, der ein bisschen was mit der Stellenanzeige zu tun hat,
so, also, du entwickelst Automatismen, das passt auch wunderbar dabei, zu deinem Repertoire, ich hoffe, ich habe das keck-keck-french richtig ausgesprochen, gehörende Überwachung von Systemen, Fehleranalyse, Problemlösung, das passt auch wunderbar dazu,
du arbeitest an der Weiterentwicklung unserer IT-Sicherheitskonzepte und Hardening-Tools, ja, okay, passt auch, mit regelmäßigen Security-Checks deckst du potenzielle Schwachstellen frühzeitig auf und setzt geeignete Sicherheitsmaßnahmen,
Security-Checks, das ist sowas, das schreiben immer alle, dass sie es machen, aber es will keiner, dass es gemacht wird, weil das nervt immer nur, so nach dem Motto, ah, wir sind eh schon ein bisschen in Verzug, eigentlich müssten wir jetzt noch Tests ABC machen und wir müssen auch noch Ausfalltests machen und wir müssen auch noch irgendein Betriebshandbuch schreiben und, ah, eigentlich müssen wir das und das auch noch dokumentieren,
ach, wisst ihr was, wir müssen eigentlich morgen live gehen, lasst das mal alles weg, das wird schon passen, also so läuft es halt meistens dann, aber ist ja gut, wenn die es wirklich ernst meinen, der Chat wieder, man, mit Regel, also, du vertiefst, erweiterst und teilst dein Wissen zu unserem, warum ist die Musik so laut, ist gar nicht so laut, du vertiefst, erweiterst und teilst dein Wissen zu unserem Tech-Stack, Ansible, shit,
Oracle Enterprise Linux, ja, wahrscheinlich aus Lizenzgründen für irgendwelche Datenbanken, vermutlich, vermutlich, aber es ist schon etwas MonkaS, so, Red Hat Enterprise, Linux Forever, ja, okay, das ist relativ, sagen wir mal, normal hier, ist nichts super Außergewöhnliches dabei,
Rufbereitschaftsdienste gehören als unverzichtbarer Bestandteil deines verantwortungsvollen Jobs dazu, sie sind ein zusätzlicher Herausforderung, die wir wertschätzen und honorieren, ja, finde ich nicht schlimm, gibt es bei uns auf der Arbeit auch, gibt ordentlich extra Kohle, kein Problem mit, das, also, ob Rufbereitschaftsdienste, ob die gut oder schlecht sind, das hängt eigentlich von genau einem Faktor ab, wie ordentlich werden Systeme eingeführt, ja,
also, wenn Systeme live genommen werden, die noch halb kaputt sind, halb in Entwicklung stecken und man quasi bei jeder Rufbereitschaft nachts angerufen wird, dann ist das scheiße, wenn das alles ordentlich läuft, dass das wirklich die Ausnahme ist, paar mal im Jahr, wenn es hochkommt, dass da irgendwas kommt, dann ist es gut, oder es muss wirklich enorm gut bezahlt sein, weil wenn da wirklich gefühlt jede zweite Rufbereitschaft nachts irgendjemand anruft, der hat ja keinen Bock drauf,
das ist richtig, das habe ich auf der Arbeit auch schon angesprochen, ja, können wir gleich gucken, das habe ich auf der Arbeit auch schon angesprochen, weil wir haben ein super weitreichendes Technologie, wie nennt man das, wie heißt denn das, so, Stack, Portfolio, keine Ahnung, also, wir haben ja alles, ja, es gibt bei uns auf der Arbeit einfach alles,
wenn ihr ne Frage habt, ob es das bei uns auf der Arbeit irgendwo gibt, aber mir irgendwo auf der Arbeit gibt, könnt ihr davon ausgehen, es gibt es, in irgendeiner Art und Weise, ja, von SAP bis 50 verschiedene Datenbanken, ok, zumindest bei Linux sind sie sich relativ einig, es gibt alles irgendwie, ja, und dementsprechend habe ich auch schon gesagt, Leute, also, wenn mich jetzt zu System XY nachts einer anruft, da kann ich nichts dazu sagen, ich kann mich da drauf einloggen, ich kann so die Basic-Linux-Sachen gucken,
so, laufen Prozesse noch, irgendwelche Logs, die voll gelaufen sind, hängen irgendwelche Mounts oder so, ja, ich kann ins Monitoring gucken, ob das was Auslagekräftiges sagt, mal irgendwie Volltext-Suche in den Docs machen, ob da was zusteht zu dem Fehler, aber wirklich, fundiert Auskennmedien mit jedem System kannst du vergessen, und ja, das wissen die auch, finde ich auch gut, dass sie das gesagt haben,
und auch meine Team-Mates auf der Arbeit haben auch gesagt, das geht uns bei den Systemen ganz genauso, obwohl wir viel länger da sind schon, und wir kennen auch nur unsere Systeme richtig gut und können bei den anderen nur Basics machen, das wissen unsere Chefs auch, das heißt, im Endeffekt, und die haben das auch gesagt, es reicht ihnen, wenn einer da ist, das einschätzen kann und Basic-Linux-Sachen dran vornehmen kann an den Systemen, wo er halt nicht dafür zuständig ist,
da kriegt man das meiste wahrscheinlich schon aus dem, ja, aus dem Weg geschafft und hat ein bisschen Zeit, die Leute anzuklingeln, die vielleicht mehr Ahnung haben, und dafür, ey, ist okay, wenn das im Vorfeld alle Beteiligten wissen und sich darauf committet haben, dann ist das okay, ob die sich im Zweifelsfall dran halten, wenn's denn mal hart auf hart kommt, das muss ich noch zeigen, das war bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber zum Beispiel nicht so,
da haben sie auch immer am Anfang erzählt, so nach dem Motto, ja, man kann nicht alles wissen, aber wenn's dann kaputt gegangen ist, dann sollte man doch alles wissen, mal gucken, wie da Realität, bin ich mal gespannt drauf, ich hoffe, ich lande nicht in der Situation, ja, aber wie da Realität und so in Einklang sind, aber das bringt ordentlich Kohlerufbereitschaft, also ich würd nicht sagen, fickt euch ins Knie, sondern am besten super stabil laufendes System plus Rufbereitschaft,
das ist eigentlich die beste Lizenz zum Geld machen, die es gibt, ja, wie gesagt, bei mir auch so, aber scheinen alle fein damit zu sein.
Würdest du als jemand, der gerade frisch aus dem Schulen kommt, ein LinkedIn oder Xing-Profil machen oder so? Ja, klar, warum nicht, also Xing würde ich nicht mehr machen, Xing ist eh schon immer so ein deutsches Ding gewesen, LinkedIn ist eigentlich das, wo's abgeht, ehrlich gesagt, ist Xing überhaupt noch in irgendeiner, auch in Deutschland irgendwie beliebt? Nee, oder? Xing ist doch eigentlich komplett für den Arsch, oder?
Also ich bin weder bei LinkedIn noch bei Xing, ich kann da nicht mitreden, das müsst ihr mir sagen, die Chat-Gir ist Social-Media-Profi, was das angeht, also ich glaube, in Deutschland war Xing mal beliebt, aber jetzt auch nicht mehr.
Echt? Wirklich? Ist wirklich Xing immer noch? Ich dachte, LinkedIn ist das Ding schlechthin. LinkedIn ist doch auch das, wo die ganzen Möchtegern-Elon-Musks ihre Blog-Einträge posten. Was für krasse, krasse Sigma-Mail-Manager sie sind.
Bald mit Physi-Ausbildung fertig, dann geht's endlich in die interne und weg aus der, jo, ist nice, ist gut, dass du direkt was gefunden hast nach der Ausbildung. Ja, genau die, da hab ich jetzt gar nicht dran gedacht, aber ja, das gibt's ja auch.
So, dann lass uns mal hier fertig gucken. Also, das, finde ich, sieht alles richtig gut passend zu dem Titel aus. Ja, es ist jetzt nichts drin, wo ich sagen würde, alter, die suchen eine ganze IT-Abteilung oder was hat das damit zu tun, passt wunderbar.
Skills. Du hast ein Studium oder Ausbildungsschwerpunkt. Okay, übliche Geschichte. Dein Know-How im Umgang mit Linux. Moment, ich kann nicht mehr lesen richtig, ja. Danielul, dankeschön, 52 Monate. Massive Subscription, dankeschön.
Excellent, 52 Monate. Deine Gehaltseinstellung. Branche, Region, keine Ahnung. Muss ich mir erstmal überlegen. Virtualisierung, Netzwerkbestandteile wie Firewalls, Router und Switcher sind für dich keine Fremdwörter?
Oh, okay. Ich mein, man muss sagen, das ist schon relativ weit gefasst. Letztendlich, Linux, ja, okay, wunderbar, aber Firewall, Router, Switcher, Virtualisierung, Linux, das ist zwar oftmals so im Linux-Umfeld, aber mit Linux direkt hat das wenig zu tun und das sind, wenn man es mal streng nimmt, ist jedes davon ein eigenes Feld, ja.
Als Linux-Admin hast du das eine, als VMware-Admin das andere oder als Netzwerk-Admin das andere. Aber wenn der Laden nicht so groß ist oder, sagen wir mal, die Aufgabengebiete so ein bisschen ineinander übergehen, ist es natürlich immer nicht verkehrt, ein bisschen was vom anderen auch noch zu verstehen.
Erste Berührungspunkte mit Automatisierungstools wie Ansible sind ein großes Plus? Ja, verständlich. Also ich denke heutzutage, wenn sich einer als Linux-Admin oder generell als, muss ja nicht mehr Admin sein, ja, also im IT-Bereich bewirbt und gerade wenn es in Richtung Linux und Cloud, Linux in der Cloud geht oder auch Linux im eigenen Rechenzentrum oder On-Prem, wie das ja heutzutage alle coolen Leute nennen,
dann kann man eigentlich erwarten, dass die Leute ein bisschen Ahnung von Automatisierungstools haben. Und Ansible ist wahrscheinlich das verbreitetste, wo du die meisten Leute für findest, also finde ich nicht verkehrt, das reinzuschreiben. Früher war Puppet angesagt, weiß nicht, jemand von euch mal ein bisschen was mit Puppet gemacht?
Ich persönlich finde Puppet gar nicht so übel, hat ein paar coole Sachen, die Ansible nicht hat, dafür ist Ansible insgesamt deutlich angenehmer zu schreiben, finde ich. Ich habe früher auch mal schon Sachen noch mit CFEngine gemacht, falls mal einer die Ära hatte, mit CFEngine was zu machen.
Aber Ansible ist, was Serverkonfiguration angeht, eigentlich so, sagen wir mal, ziemlich Standard. In der Cloud ist es meistens, wenn man es ordentlich macht, eher so, dass man Ansible gar nicht braucht, da geht es eher ums Infrastruktur-Professionieren und dann ist es meistens Terraform. Gibt sowas wie Pulumi, gibt es auch noch, aber meistens ist es Terraform.
Und die Systeme sind da so weit, quasi, ja, self-contained, dass man meistens kein Ansible mehr braucht, aber das geht voll klar. Oh, das ist richtig, das stelle ich mir eklig vor zusammen.
Mann als Noob, was macht man im Alltag mit Ansible? Okay, Beispiel, ja, Beispiel. So ganz, Cloud und so alles außen vor, sagen wir mal, ganz klassische Sache. Stell dir mal vor, du betreibst irgendeinen Online-Shop, okay, und der Online-Shop besteht aus ein paar Datenbank-Servern, ein paar Backend-Servern, ein paar Web-Servern, die das HTML-Zeug ausliefert, so.
Also du hast quasi so eine Umgebung für deinen Web-Shop, besteht, sagen wir mal so, aus 30 Linux-Servern, ja, ungefähr, alles dabei. Frontend, Datenbank, Analyse-Tools und sonst was in der Richtung, sagen wir mal 30, 30 Server.
So, und jetzt hast du das Problem, dir geht einer der Server kaputt und die musst du neu aufbauen. Das kann ja auch mal eine VM, muss ja nicht immer eine Hardware sein, die ausfällt. Und jetzt willst du diesen Server neu aufbauen. Wie hast du das früher gemacht?
Früher bist du dann hingegangen, hast dir eine VM angelegt, hast ein ISO reingemountet, hast das von dem ISO das Betriebssystem installiert und dann nach bestem Wissen und Gewissen den Server so konfiguriert von Hand, dass er das macht, was er machen soll, ja.
Du hast den Nginx draufgehauen, du hast den Postgres draufgehauen, du hast PHP vielleicht auch früher draufgehauen, du hast deine Anwendung draufgeschoben, was auch immer, ja, was auch immer. Und dann stellst du dir irgendwann fest, oh Mist, es gibt immer mal wieder Fehler auf dieser Kiste, weil, ja, vielleicht hast du vergessen, dass die Verzeichnisberechtigung unter Wahl BWW irgendwie anders sein müssen.
Ja, und dann hast du ein paar User, die konnten den Webshop nicht richtig benutzen und haben vielleicht den Bestellvorgang abgebrochen, weil dein Server halt nicht richtig funktioniert hat. Das ist doof, hat vielleicht irgendwie 5.000, 6.000 Euro jetzt gekostet, dass sie das nicht durchführen konnten.
Und wenn du sowas wie Ansible benutzt, dann kannst du diesen Server aufbauen, lässt Ansible laufen und der Server ist exakt in der Konfiguration, wie du es haben willst.
Also wenn du das Ganze containerisiert machst, kommt drauf an, in welchem Umfang. Also ganz im Ernst, wenn deine Produktionskisten hauptsächlich auf Container-Workloads basieren, dann würde ich mir tatsächlich mal über ein Kubernetes Gedanken machen.
Weil das ist da wie gemacht dafür. Wobei ich sagen würde, ich würde Kubernetes nur beschränkt empfehlen zum Selbstinstallieren und komplett selbst administrieren.
Du kannst aber glaube ich auch Docker Compose im Ansible machen, wobei ganz ehrlich, das kannst du machen, ist vielleicht nicht so sinnvoll. Du würdest dann aber in Ansible zum Beispiel so Sachen reinschreiben, wie du legst 2, 3 User auf der Kiste an.
Du machst einen App-Install-Docker, einen App-Install-Docker-Compose. Du guckst, dass alle SSH-Keys von den ganzen Admins verteilt sind. Es gibt da sehr viele Sachen, an die man vielleicht gar nicht so direkt denkt, die aber gemacht werden müssen, nachdem ein neuer Server installiert wird, dass der überhaupt am Ende so funktionieren kann, wie er funktionieren soll.
Also Ansible ist zum Server-Konfigurieren. Du baust das System auf, damit hat Ansible nichts zu tun. Und dann lässt du Ansible laufen und Ansible bringt den Server in die Konfiguration, wie er sein soll. Man kann das beliebig komplexer machen.
Es gibt bestimmt auch die Möglichkeit, dass du so Dinge machst, wie automatisch ins Load-Balancing aufnehmen und sowas mit Ansible. Wobei ich das irgendwie mit Service-Discovery machen würde auf dem Load-Balancer und nicht direkt, dass Ansible da irgendwas am Load-Balancer dreht. Ja, gibt's jede Menge.
Im Cloud-Umfeld ist Ansible nicht mehr so angesagt, weil dort die meisten Kisten quasi mit dem Aufbauen fertig sind. In der Cloud werden es eh immer zunehmend weniger VMs, aber oftmals macht man es da so, dass man es möglichst kleinteilig aufbaut und dass die Dinge nach dem Professionieren quasi einfach funktionieren.
Du lässt vielleicht auch ein Cloud-Init laufen auf deiner VM und das ist gut. Wenn du Cloud-Server hast, wo du viel konfigurieren musst, extra User unter Linux anlegen, Verzeichnisse anlegen, Datei-Berechtigung, eigene Mount-Points, irgendwelche Custom-Pakete drauf und so, dann kannst du auch im Cloud-Init Ansible laufen lassen.
Dann hast du ein Terraform zum Professionieren deiner VM-Infrastruktur in der Cloud und danach lässt du über Terraform ein Cloud-Init laufen, der Ansible ausführt und Ansible konfiguriert die Kiste dann. Aber das ist ein bisschen umständlich. Es ist immer gut, wenn die Kisten so self-contained quasi aufgebaut werden, dass man nicht viel konfigurieren muss. Dann kann man es auch einfacher wegschmeißen.
So, aber jetzt habe ich ein bisschen sidetracken lassen. Wir sind immer noch hier dabei. Also bis jetzt passt das eigentlich ziemlich gut. Du gehst lösungsorientiert und flexibel mit neuen Techniken heraus. Okay, bla bla bla bla. Ja, passt auch.
Modern ausgestatteter Arbeitsplatz. Flexible Arbeitszeiten. Flexible Home-Office-Optionen. Das ist das einzige, wo das Icon nicht die richtige Farbe hat. Da hat der CSS-Mann gefailt. Oder mein Darkreader hat gefailt. Die zwei Varianten gibt es natürlich.
Was ihr habt gesagt, hier gibt es auch einen Obstkorb. Ne, gibt es nicht. Was ja mittlerweile eher positiv zu werten ist. Formen kenne ich. Formen haben wir auch eine Weile benutzt beim alten Arbeitgeber. Fand ich aber nie so geil ehrlich gesagt. Ist natürlich gut, kannst du PXE-Boot machen, Betriebssystem installieren. Aber irgendwie bin ich mit Formen nie so richtig warm geworden.
Also finde ich, das ist nicht schlecht. Das ist jetzt vielleicht keine Stellanzeige, wo ich sagen würde, oh ja, die sprüht vor Innovationen. Also nicht unbedingt von der Stelle, sondern super innovativ geschrieben oder so. Aber passt zu der Beschreibung und vom Inhalt her würde ich sagen, passt auch gut.
Zum Gehaltsforderung, Leute, ich kann euch dazu nichts sagen. Es ist nicht so, als wäre ich irgendwie krasser Personalvermittlungs-Dude, der deutschlandweit Erfahrung hat oder sowas. Ich kann euch, wenn überhaupt, was sagen, was Frankfurter Versicherung und Bankenumfeld angeht und Frankfurter Finanzbranche ein bisschen, aber ansonsten.
Wir hatten doch letztens mal mein Einstiegsgehalt hochgerechnet. 30-35k nach Ausbildung ist viel zu wenig. 30-35k nach Ausbildung hatte ich ja schon und das ist über 10 Jahre her.
Wir hatten letztens mal mein Einstiegsgehalt, ich glaube beim Spiegel hatten wir das irgendwie, oder? Wo war das denn, Spiegel? Hier, Inflationsrechner hatten wir doch hier. Hier, Bruttogehalt 33.500 war in 2007, ist jetzt 46k. Also ich finde, 46k ist nach der Ausbildung ein guter, also war auch in Frankfurt, ja, ist denke ich ein gutes Einstiegsgehalt.
Ich denke, da kann man mal anpeilen. Also habe ich jetzt hochgerechnet aus meinem Einstiegsgehalt. Kommt sicherlich extrem auf die Region an, das wird in Frankfurt mehr sein als irgendwie im Osten auf dem Land oder so. Vermutlich, vielleicht haben die da auch so IT-Mangel, dass es da mehr ist, kann man immer schlecht sagen. Es ist auf jeden Fall sehr abhängig von Region und auch ein bisschen von der Branche.
Man muss halt sagen, Versicherung und Banken und gerade in Frankfurt bezahlen halt, gibt's ja auch Statistik drüber, bezahlen halt wirklich echt nicht schlecht. Ich glaube gefolgt von Pharmaindustrie und gefolgt von Automobilindustrie, wenn ich es richtig im Kopf habe. Ah, Zertifikate bringen nix. Also meiner Ansicht nach bringen Zertifikate nix. Ich würde da auch nichts drauf geben, wenn einer an Kubanä das Zertifikat hat.
Also ich würde im Vorstellungsgespräch nicht fragen, haben sie ein Kubanänes Zertifikat, wenn einer, waren die Stellen, die wir sind gerade dabei, wenn einer sagt Kubanänes Erfahrung, dann würde ich denen irgendwas Praktisches fragen. So, keine Ahnung, wie stellst du bei einem Ingress die, wie lässt du einem Ingress eine neue externe IP zuweisen, zum Beispiel.
Sowas in der Richtung, wo man halt merkt, okay, der hat ein bisschen Ahnung davon, was er macht. Der Config-File bringt dir in dem Fall so beschränkt was. Also, du musst halt wissen, was du da reinschreibst oder was du mit kubctl machst und ein paar Stichwörter würde ich dann schon hören wollen.
Oh nein, also 45% musst du doch erstmal hinkriegen. Du bist ja hier anonym, dann erhelle uns doch mal, ich nehme ja immer meine Sachen als Vergleich, wenn mich einer was fragt, aber es ist auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt, wenn wir ein bisschen mehr Vergleich haben, dann erhelle uns doch mal Sanjo, welche Branche bzw. welche Region, wenn du die Branche nicht sagen willst und was hast du vorgekriegt und was kriegst du jetzt.
Und sag mal so auch das Tätigkeitsbereich, wenn du die exakte Stellenbezeichnung nicht sagen willst. Umso mehr Vergleichssachen wir haben, umso besser.
Das glaube ich nicht, dass Zertifikate viel bringen. Ich kenne keinen, der auf Zertifikate guckt. Vielleicht, wenn du dich beim Amt bewirbst.
Haben die das nach Regionen aufgesplittet? Ansonsten bringt dir der bundesweite Durchschnitt für deine Sache nicht sonderlich viel.
Wie lange haben bei dir die Rückmeldung auf deine Bewerbung gebraucht?
Sehr schnell. Also ich habe in meinem Leben nicht viele Bewerbungen geschrieben. Es ist nicht so, als hätte ich da jetzt krasse Erfahrungen.
Also für die Ausbildungsstelle habe ich glaube ich zwei Bewerbungen oder so geschrieben und weiß ich gar nicht, ob ich von den einen was gehört habe.
Die anderen haben sich relativ schnell gemeldet und nach Vorstellungsgespräch haben sie mich einen Tag später angerufen und haben gesagt, ja wollen sie.
Und jetzt beim letzten, beim letzten musste ich ja gar nicht mal richtig Bewerbung schreiben. Da wurde ich ja angerufen.
Also kann ich jetzt nicht sagen. Mir fehlen die Stichproben dafür. Ne Studiumssachen kann ich dir nicht helfen.
Okay, dann würde ich mal sagen. Das Hammer. Dann next.
IT-Admin macOS. Das ist mal was besonderes. Das sieht man selten. Windows-Admins in Massen. Linux auch in Massen. Aber Mac? Mac noch nicht.
Das ist doch bestimmt irgendeine Marketingagentur oder sowas. Wenn die macOS-Leute suchen. Was ist das?
Man kann das ja kaum lesen. Das liegt aber bestimmt an meinem.
Das ist eine wirklich schlechte Wahl der Schriftfarbe auf dem Hintergrund.
Let's build the amazing, the incredible, the impossible. Alter, jetzt ist ja mal gut. Regt euch ab.
One global team. A world of opportunities. A world of friends from... What the... Ach du... Ne, ne, ne.
Keine Ahnung was bei denen abgeht.
So, also was gibt es denn hier schönes?
Admin macOS. Für unseren Standort in Hamburg mit ca. 130 Mitarbeitern suchen wir deinen Support als IT-Systemadministrator. All genders.
Du kümmerst dich um die Geräte überwiegend Macbooks. Okay, das finde ich schon mal cool. Besser als den Windows-Mist mit dem ich mich da rumschlage.
Also, ich bin kein Windows-Admin. Ich benutze den Kram nur.
Besser als mit dem Windows-Mist mit dem ich mich da rumschlagen muss.
Und leiste Support für unsere Mitarbeiter. Sorgst aber auch dafür, dass unser modernes Office über den Dächern Hamburgs stets gut und sicher...
Sag mal, wie viele Dächer hat Hamburg eigentlich? Gefühlt in jeder zweiten Stellenanzeige, wo was von Hamburg steht, steht über den Dächern Hamburgs.
Haben die irgendwie da so einen Kletterwald oder wo die alle sind?
Die Website hat kein Impressum mehr. Das wirkt doch schon... Naja gut, das hier ist glaube ich... Keine Ahnung was das ist.
Impressum ist outdated, overrated. DSGVO-Abmahnung ist raus.
Ach, du meinst wegen Überschwemmungen in Hamburg sind die alle auf dem Dach. Ja gut.
Giplab benutzen die. Alles klar. Easy.
Giplab. Da hat ja der Experte geschrieben wieder.
Okay, neue Kollegen begleitest du im Onboarding durch die Bestellung der Hardware und die Einrichtung aller notwendigen Accounten. Im Offboarding sorgt... Okay, bla bla bla bla.
Zusätzlich zur Geräteausstellung kümmerst du dich um die Arbeitsplätze unserer Mitarbeiter und stellst auch entsprechende Tische bereit.
What? Du stellst auch entsprechende Tische bereit? Also ich weiß nicht, ich gehe in den Keller und trage den Tisch hoch und stelle... Ja gut.
Da hätte ich jetzt persönlich keinen Bock drauf, aber wenn sie es ordentlich bezahlen, trage ich den auch am Tisch.
Du unterstützt bei Verwaltung der Mitarbeiteraccounts unter anderem Google, Slack, Jira, Confluence, Giplab.
Genauso gehört die Verwaltung der Softwarelizenzen zu deinem Aufgabenbereich.
Okay, das ist super vage. Die Verwaltung der Softwarelizenzen ist wahrscheinlich auf Serials Punkt, ich sag's jetzt nicht, zu gehen und sich was rauszusuchen.
Das kann ich dir ganz einfach beantworten. Guck dir doch auf YouTube, falls du es noch nicht gesehen hast, das Video an, was ich aktuell verdiene.
Und darunter hätte ich keinen Bock, was Neues zu machen. Ich hätte allgemein keinen Bock, was Neues zu machen zur Zeit.
Es sei denn, es ist wirklich irgendwas, was ich mir jetzt nicht ausmalen kann und so geil finde und vielleicht noch besser bezahlt, dass ich nicht widerstehen könnte.
Aber das sieht aktuell nicht so aus. Also sagen wir mal, unter 110k im Jahr, also für 5 Tage gerechnet, kannst dann runterrechnen auf meine 4 Tage, würde ich mir das nicht überlegen.
Es muss eher noch eine Ecke mehr sein, dass ich es mir überhaupt überlege, zumal dann bei mir noch der Bonus dabei kommt.
Da müsste schon ordentlich was rumkommen.
Ich sag mal, für 150k und eine super Stelle, würde ich es mir überlegen, aber ich habe keine Wechselinteressen aktuell.
Aber man soll ja nie sagen, man weiß ja nicht, was da noch kommt da.
Ah, hier, es ist interessant.
Wegen den 45% Mehrgehalt aktuell, IT-Systemkaufmann, IHK-Ausbildung.
Das ist ja nicht schlecht, also du bist ja quasi erst, naja fast fertig, seit 4 Jahren fertig.
Finanzbranche in Düsseldorf, 41k IT-DevOps, bisher gewesen, oder?
Und dann bist du ab 1.1.65k in Köln, Versicherungssoftware, ja, das ist natürlich ein ganz guter Sprung.
Wobei man auch wirklich sagen muss, 41k für einen DevOps-Engineer ist halt echt schon ein bisschen sehr knauserig.
Und ich denke, mit dem Gehalt hast du gute Chancen, die nächsten Jahre nochmal einen ganz, ganz guten Sprung zu machen.
Wenn du was drauf hast und das, sagen wir mal, wenigstens semi-gut verkaufen kannst, wie gesagt, es ist ja immer mindestens genauso wichtig,
so viel Zeit reinzustecken, über das zu reden, was man Tolles gemacht hat, wie tolle Sachen zu machen,
dann gibt's Stonks die nächsten Jahre über.
Geht's nach oben.
Hä? Verstehe ich nicht.
Was?
Ich bin alt? Ja, ich bin alt.
Ich hab keine NDA?
Was willst du denn wissen? Ich versteh's nicht.
Ja, ja, Leute, lasst euch von dem was, das ist das Gleiche wie auf Reddit.
Ihr müsst bei Reddit, Slash, Subreddit Arbeitsleben gucken, da ist jedes zweite Kommentar,
sofort kündigen, dem Chef auf den Tisch kacken und einen neuen Job suchen.
Oder so, unter 80k steh ich gar nicht mehr auf.
Lasst euch von irgendwelchen Gelabern im Internet nicht ganz so sehr beeinflussen.
Ja, ist halt so.
Wie gesagt, es kommt enorm auf die Branche und die Region an.
Also ich kann dir das gerne beantworten, aber du musst mir erklären, was du meinst.
Also, ich meine, wenn du sagst, ich will 110k plus, ich stehe dann vor dir, der dich anstellt,
wie würdest du argumentieren?
Gar nicht. Ich würde es einfach nicht in Erwägung ziehen, wenn ich weniger bekomme.
Ganz einfach.
Ich würde gar nicht vor dir stehen, wenn du weniger bietest,
weil ich keinerlei Interesse habe zu wechseln und dann schon irgendwas super krasses kommen muss,
dass ich jetzt halt gerade wechseln würde.
Ja, also ich denke, mit vier Jahren Erfahrung ist das durchaus noch im okayen Bereich.
Wobei ich denke, wenn wir mal sagen, so Einstiegsgehalt von 45k,
wie gesagt, ich kann es immer nur von meinem Einstiegsgehalt ausgehen, hochgerechnet auf die aktuelle Zeit,
ist nach vier Jahren, sagen wir mal 55k, jetzt vielleicht so ein bisschen,
also auch 100% Stelle nehme ich mal an, vielleicht so eher am unteren Ende.
Also du hast auf jeden Fall Chancen, das noch ordentlich zu steigern die nächsten Jahre über.
Ob es bei deinem Arbeitgeber geht, das kann ich jetzt auch nicht wissen.
Wie findest du Jobs im Security-Bereich?
Boah, warte, was?
Das ist so wie, wie findest du Jobs im Automobil-Bereich.
Das kann ja alles sein.
Kann ich nicht aufsprechen, danke für den Sub.
Also ich versuche mal trotzdem was Gescheites dazu zu sagen.
Also mal angenommen, aus irgendwelchen Gründen hätte ich jetzt keinen Job.
Gehen wir mal davon aus. Also aus irgendwelchen Gründen hätte ich keinen Job.
Und ich würde mich irgendwo bewerben und wir hätten ein Vorstellungsgespräch
und ich würde da sitzen und du würdest mich fragen, wie viel wollen sie haben.
So meinst du das, oder?
Ja, dann würde ich tatsächlich auch 110k oder 105k oder irgendwie, wahrscheinlich würde ich 110k sagen.
Allein schon aus dem Grund, weil du musst ja irgendwie meine Hausnummer sagen.
Und nachdem es eigentlich immer weniger ist als das, was du gesagt hast, kann das ruhig erstmal ein bisschen zu viel sein.
Und wie ich das dann argumentieren würde ist, naja, es kommt auf die Stellenanzeige an.
Ich meine, je nachdem wie gut und nicht gut das passt, ich mache den Kram seit 15 Jahren,
ich kenne mich in den und den Bereichen super aus, wofür sie mich brauchen.
Das kommt auf die Situation an. Ich glaube nicht, dass es eine universelle, keine Ahnung,
Vorstellungsgesprächsargumentation gibt, wo man immer exakt sein Wunschgehalt bekommt.
Ja, geht ja noch weiter. Du kannst ja noch Architekt werden, falls es sowas gibt bei euch.
Typhoon, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Stand jetzt, welche Ausbildung würdest du heute machen?
Wahrscheinlich wieder die gleiche.
So, jetzt sollten wir mal weitermachen hier.
Wo bin ich denn hier gelandet?
Was ist das? Bist du...
Warte mal, wir waren mit der anderen noch gar nicht fertig, oder?
Also, der MacOS-Admin, du bist mitverhandelt für die Internetseite am Standort WLAN, VPN, Switch, Firewall.
Neben unserem Videokonferenzsystem wird noch die Telefon...
Ja, Alter, jetzt ist ja mal gut, ey!
Jetzt übertreibst du es aber.
Ey, Mann, also komm, jetzt ist irgendwann mal gut.
Jetzt ist irgendwann mal gut.
Die wollen, dass du...
Okay, du bist IT-Admin, du bist IT-Systemadministrator für, okay, MacOS.
Meinetwegen, du sollst jetzt...
Also, du sollst die Leute on und off boaren mit den Geräten, das verstehe ich irgendwie noch.
Ganz ehrlich, Inventarisierung und sonst was und Hardwarebestellung ist eigentlich nicht deine Aufgabe,
aber lass ich mir in dem kleinen Laden irgendwie noch ein bisschen gefallen, okay.
Dass ich seriously Tische tragen muss, kann man vielleicht auch noch irgendwie machen, wenn man da keine Probleme hat.
Ich hätte da zum Beispiel keinen Bock.
So, dann kümmerst du dich um die Softwareverwaltung, kümmerst dich um das Accountmanagement für den ganzen Campbell oder auch für GibLab.
Dann kümmerst du dich um Netzwerke, um ihr WLAN, um ihr VPN-Zeug, um ihre Switch und Firewalls.
ETC gibt es wahrscheinlich noch mehr und die Fritzbox wahrscheinlich auch.
Wahrscheinlich haben die noch eine Fritzbox irgendwo stehen.
Dann sollst du noch nebenbei Videokonferenzsysteme machen, Telefonanlage und dann auch noch die fucking Drucker und Scanner.
Jetzt ist ja irgendwann mal gut.
Und dann sollst du End-User-Support machen.
Ne, also das ist bescheuert.
Wird noch besser, kann ja fast noch nicht besser werden.
Ist das eine G-Bait-Anzeige oder was?
Neben der technischen Betreuung kümmerst du dich auch um zum Beispiel Verkabelung im Office an...
Das ist doch ein Witz, das ist doch ein Witz, oder?
Das ist doch ein Witz.
Das... okay, Leute, ich weiß, ich weiß, was das ist.
Ohne G-Bait.
Ich scrolle jetzt runter gleich und unten drunter steht's sinngemäß R-G-Baited.
Sinngemäß R-G-Baited, wir suchen einfach nur den Besten oder sowas.
Ja, also...
Das wird bestimmt jetzt immer, immer abgedrehter.
Und am Ende steht, wir haben dich nur verarscht, aber wir suchen dich trotzdem.
Anders kann ich mir das langsam nicht mehr erklären.
Okay, wir tun mal so, als wäre es ernst, okay?
Neben der technischen Betreuung kümmerst du dich auch um zum Beispiel Verkabelung im Office anbringen von...
Ach, Fernsehern, ich hab Fenster gelesen, ich hab Fenster gelesen, aber...
Okay, Fernsehern oder den Austausch von Klübien und sorgst dafür, dass unser Office nicht nur technisch gut ausgeht, sondern auch...
What the fuck, Alter, was ist mit denen los?
Das ist so schlecht, das muss ich... Also, falls ich das wirklich ernst mache, das muss ich mir speichern.
Klübien wechseln.
Verkabelung!
Vieles davon darfst du als random IT-Dude gar nicht verkabeln.
Okay, Qualifikation, das bringst du mit.
Du hast eine abgeschlossene Ausbildung im IT-Bereich.
Ja, okay.
Erste Erfahrung mit Administration, Betreuung von IT... Achso, also ja, erste Erfahrungen reichen sicherlich aus, um die komplette IT-Abteilung alleine zu geben. Ja, gar kein Problem.
Genau, du bist Elektriker, Administrator und Hausmeister.
Und Umzugshelfer.
Ich meine, man könnte sicherlich auch mal neu streichen, oder?
So ein bisschen Farbe an die Wand ab und zu, wenn es nicht mal agile genug ist, das Büro.
Wenn es nicht mal diagonal skaliert, dann muss man eine andere Farbe hin.
Erste Erfahrungen mit der Administration.
Okay, du besitzt Kenntnisse und Erfahrungen mit Mac, macOS und unserer Tool-Landschaft.
Google Suite, Slack, Jira, Confluent... Ach ja, das GitLab, okay.
Vielleicht, genau, vielleicht sind die Clos auch mal verstopft zwischendurch.
Du bist... Warum bin ich eine Ganzzahl?
Und hast ein ausgeprägtes Sicherheitsverständnis.
Du schreckst vor handwerklichen Tätigkeiten nicht zurück.
Also, da muss ich sagen, ich schrecke tatsächlich vor handwerklichen Tätigkeiten nicht zurück.
Ich mache ziemlich viel bei mir daheim. Ich bastel auch unglaublich gerne.
Und seit ich mein Fahrrad habe, bin ich auch öfters am Fahrrad schrauben, obwohl ich davon keinen Plan habe.
Und lerne das auch gerne und sowas.
Aber nicht in meinem Job.
Selbst da würde ich es machen, aber es ist halt nicht mein Job, das zu machen.
Also, ich würde gerne ab und zu noch mal im Rechenzentrum ein paar Server schrauben.
Hätte ich gar kein Problem mit, ja.
Aber Klübeln wechseln vielleicht dann doch nicht.
Nice to have. Du bist Fachkraft für Arbeitssicherheit, für die sicherheitstechnische Betreuung.
Auch noch, okay.
Gute kommunikative Fähigkeit.
In Deutsch und Englisch runden dein Profil ab. Wir bieten dir einen Job in vollster Detail.
Du entscheidest, wenn du willst, Einstieg in die FFW-Band.
Die verarschen uns doch, oder?
Quereinsteiger sind willkommen.
FFW wird klimaneutral mit Agencies for Future.
Das reißt jetzt auch noch mehr raus.
Hybrides Arbeitmodell. Kombi aus Remote und Office mit Flex.
Wird schwierig aus dem Homeoffice die Klübeln dazu wechseln.
Wöchentliches gemeinsames Frühstück und Lunch-Lotterie.
Das klingt nach gezwungenen sozialen Events.
Ein offener Zuschuss für ÖPNV.
Ich weiß ja nicht, Leute.
Lunch-Lotterie ist, dass man random Leute zum Mittag schickt.
Ach, ist das so ein...
Heute treffen sich random Leute beim Mittag?
Oh, nee. Das ist so krass gezwungen, da hätte ich überhaupt keinen Bock.
Gibt's bei mir auf der Arbeit auch.
Ich hab mal ganz kurz überlegt, ganz am Anfang, als ich neu war,
ob ich das mir nicht einmal angucken soll, weil man...
Sag mal, es ist immer doof,
über was abzulästern, was man noch gar nicht ausprobiert hat.
Aber ich hab's da nicht gemacht,
weil ich finde sowas immer richtig ätzend.
Wir haben bei uns auf der Arbeit auch sowas.
Da heißt es nicht Lunch-Lotterie,
sondern, ich glaube, Mittagessen-Speed-Dating heißt es dort.
So in der Richtung heißt es, glaube ich, Mittagessen-Speed-Dating.
Aber habe ich mich nie dazu angemeldet.
Wir mussten mal, wenn du das gerade erzählst,
wir mussten mal ein Playcenter einbauen,
relativ weit oben im Rack.
Zu zweit, glücklicherweise.
Das war auch ein Akt.
Die Dinger sind übelst schwer, 8 HE groß.
Ich meine, aber seriously,
da kannst du dir echt wehtun bei, ja?
Da hättet ihr auch mal einen rüberschicken können und sagen,
hier, pass mal auf, dass das nicht auf den Fuß fällt.
Weil aus der Höhe, wenn dir die Kiste auf den Fuß fällt,
da ist der Fuß im Arsch.
Aber die hatte bestimmt Sicherheitsschuhe an, oder?
Niemand im Rechenzentrum hat Sicherheitsschuhe an, Leute.
Habt ihr, serious Frage, Leute,
an alle von euch, die noch öfters ins Rechenzentrum müssen,
habt ihr Sicherheitsschuhe an?
Niemand hat Sicherheitsschuhe an im Rechenzentrum.
Ich hätte noch nicht mal gewusst früher,
und als ich noch beim Provider gearbeitet habe,
also in der Zeit, ich habe ja oft erzählt,
es war täglich Stunden im Rechenzentrum.
Ich wusste noch nicht mal überhaupt,
wo wir Sicherheitsschuhe hätten,
gehabt hätten dafür.
Nee, die musst du nicht tragen.
Aber es wäre oftmals gerade,
wenn man schwere Kisten einbaut,
gar nicht blöd, sowas anzuziehen.
Ich habe es einmal live erlebt,
da ist einem Kollegen eine 2HP-Kiste
aus der Hand gefallen,
Höhe vom Tragen, also jetzt nicht irgendwie
aus 3 Meter Höhe auf den Fuß.
Nein, der hat den Server getragen
und ist ihm aus der Hand gefallen.
Dann ist er zurückgerutscht
und so eine vollbeladene 2HP-Kiste
mit Festplatten wiegt halt auch mal 20 Kilo.
Die ist ihm so aus Tragehöhe
mit der Kante vom Server,
so schön schräg,
schräge Kante vom Server,
auf den Fuß geklatscht.
Da war er erst mal 2 Wochen weg,
konnte nicht mehr laufen.
Glücklicherweise war der Fuß nicht durch.
Also das kann echt,
ins Auge ist falsche Formulierung,
aber ihr wisst, was ich meine,
das kann echt ins Auge gehen.
Aber niemand zieht sich Sicherheitsschuhe
im Rechenzentrum an.
Ja, Jacken,
ich würde sagen,
Jacken und Gehörschutz sind eigentlich
Standard bei den meisten.
Ich habe aber gar nichts angezogen.
Also ich hatte selten was an.
Ich hatte noch nicht mal morgens was an.
Ich habe euch ja erzählt,
ich habe morgens immer Rundgang gemacht
durch mehrere Rechenzentren im Dunklen,
weil es für mich quasi verlängerte
Nachtruhe war.
Bin quasi im Halbschlaf
im Rechenzentrum Rundgang im Dunklen.
Da konnte ich noch gefühlt
weiter schlafen dabei.
Und ich habe keine Jacke angezogen
und keinen Ohrschützer.
Ich finde den Rechenzentrumslärm
nicht schlimm.
Es wird erst schlimm,
wenn du es wirklich den ganzen Tag hast.
Also wenn du den ganzen Tag was einbaust,
dann wird es schon ätzend irgendwann.
Aber meistens muss man dann dort
auch nicht den ganzen Tag
im Rechenzentrum stehen,
sondern einbauen, verkabeln
Management Interface, sonst was.
Und da gibt es ja glücklicherweise
meistens einen eigenen Raum für.
Oder man ist ganz Hardcore
und macht es noch mit dem Rollwagen,
wo der Monitor drauf ist.
Das hätte ich auch gerne gehabt.
Aber bei uns früher haben die
lieber zwei Azubis rüber geschickt
ins Rechenzentrum,
um 8 HE-Kisten einzubauen.
Wir waren die Serverheber.
Aber ich sage euch,
wenn ihr schon mal über Kopfhöhe
ein Playcenter eingebaut habt,
dann ist der 77er nicht der Größte.
Also das geht echt auf die Arme.
Mich hast du bestimmt nicht gesehen.
Das ist schon eine ganze Weile her.
Ja, so Kisten kosten einiges.
Wir hatten auch mal
Loadbalancer für 50.000 Euro das Stück.
So Appliance-Dinger.
Normale Linienkisten kosten nicht so viel.
Die sollten wir mit so einem
komischen Bollerwagen
über eine abschüssige Straße
mehrere übereinander gestapelt rüberfahren.
Das waren Dinger.
Also die Stellanzeige ist komplett bescheuert.
Keine Ahnung, was mit denen los ist.
Ich dachte auch, die ist G-Bade,
aber anscheinend ist sie nicht G-Bade.
Anscheinend ist sie nicht G-Bade.
Ja.
Ich habe noch nie Bock drauf gehabt
und ich habe immer gesagt, will ich nicht.
Ja.
Also gerade
mein
ganz alter Chef damals,
der hat mir gefühlt
halbjährlich die Karrieremöglichkeiten
im Unternehmen immer wieder erzählt.
Und sie haben mich ja auch mal
kurzzeitig dazu genötigt,
bei einem Projekt die Vertretung
vom Projektleiter zu machen.
Das habe ich einmal und nie wieder gemacht.
Ich habe echt keinen Bock auf sowas.
In letzter Zeit ist es weniger geworden.
Beim alten Arbeitgeber ist es quasi
überhaupt nicht mehr vorgekommen.
Spätestens seit ich Teilzeit arbeite
so gut wie gar nicht mehr.
Weil die sich gedacht haben,
Max hat eh keinen Bock auf den Scheiß.
Die haben es dann langsam verstanden.
Und beim neuen wurde ich noch nicht gefragt,
aber beim neuen werde ich wahrscheinlich
auch nicht gefragt.
Da haben die so ein internes
Führungskräfte-Hörder-Ranführprogramm
und da bewerben sich die Leute drauf,
die Bock haben das zu machen.
Und die haben genug Bewerber.
Das heißt, die werden mich gar nicht fragen
und das ist auch gut so,
weil ich würde es eh nicht machen wollen.
Chat, ich würde echt mal interessieren,
was die bezahlen.
Also dafür müssten die wirklich
enorm ordentlich bezahlen,
was sie nicht machen.
Am Ende bezahlen sie wahrscheinlich
35k oder sowas
und sagen dann ja,
aber bei uns ist doch die coole
familiäre Atmosphäre,
ihr wisst schon.
Bla, bla, bla.
Also das bewirbt dich doch heute,
ja ganz bestimmt.
So, okay, glückliche Menschen
wieder am Start, Leute.
Glückliche Menschen,
alle wieder super happy
und am Lachen,
weil sie aufs Handy zeigen.
Wie in echt.
Datenbank-Ingenieur,
IT-Berater,
DB2-Zo…
Jetzt wird's aber Business-Enterprise-Kack-Finanzbranche, Alter.
MonkaStier.
Ich muss das mal kurz überfahren, Sekunde.
So, oh, okay.
Ich musste meine Abneigung da gerade mal dagegen
zum Ausdruck bringen.
Ich wollte nicht,
dass mich jetzt einer falsch übersteht,
das galt nicht meiner Katze hier unten, ja,
sondern DB2 und ZOS.
Also, die haben wohl noch einen IBM Mainframe, würde ich sagen.
Okay, bla, bla, bla, bla.
DB2 ist wahrscheinlich auch nur SQL, ja.
So wie fast jede Datenbank in irgendeiner Art und Weise SQL kann.
Wobei ich, ehrlich gesagt, gar nicht weiß,
ob DB2, wahrscheinlich können sie das aber.
ZOS ist das Betriebssystem von den ganzen IBM Mainframe-Dingern.
Die sehen so aus.
Ja, genau so sehen die aus.
Bei manchen sehen die auch noch so aus.
Aber so, so, so, sag mal, in dieser Weise sehen die aus.
Ja, die sehen immer ein bisschen anders aus.
Jedes Mal, wenn ich, wenn ich mir so,
es sieht ja ein bisschen anders aus,
aber im Prinzip sehen die Dinger so ähnlich aus.
Und wisst ihr, wisst ihr, was das ganz Tolle daran ist?
IBM hat auch ein super tolles Lizenzmodell.
Ihr denkt jetzt vielleicht,
wenn ihr euch für sehr viel Geld,
was geht denn da ab, RGB-Mod,
wenn ihr euch für sehr viel Geld einen IBM Mainframe kauft,
dann gehört er euch.
Nein, das ist nicht so, der gehört euch nicht.
Ihr müsst die Rechenleistung darauf nach wie vor bezahlen,
obwohl ihr den bei euch im Rechenzentrum stehen habt und gekauft habt.
Ihr bezahlt, ihr bezahlt quasi pro CPU in dem Ding.
Das nennt sich bei Mainframes,
es gibt so ein komisches Wort für so einen,
so einen Rechenslice bei so einem Mainframe.
Ich habe vergessen, wie das heißt.
Und bei einem Mainframe macht man auch keine Reboot,
sondern bei einem Mainframe macht man einen,
wie heißt das, LPAR oder sowas?
Chat, kennt sich jemand mit Mainframes aus?
IPL, nicht LPAR.
IPL hieß das Ding.
Genau, ja.
Ich sehe, Sajj Zilver kennt sich aus.
Ja.
Sowas suchen die anscheinend.
Ach, LPAR sind die VMs und IPL ist der,
ja Leute, wie gesagt,
ich habe damit nichts großartig zu tun.
Ich habe die letzten Jahre immer ein bisschen was aufgeschnappt.
Ich will das nicht tun als,
ich wollte jetzt nicht die Fachbegriffe droppen,
um zu zeigen, ich bin der krasse Mainframe-Kenner.
Ich habe davon überhaupt keine Ahnung.
Ein paar Sachen habe ich mitgekriegt, das war es aber auch.
Also, folgende Aufgaben fallen in ihren,
ach hier steht es doch, guck,
DB2-Datenbank im IBM ZUS-Umfeld.
Architektonische und strategische Weiterentwicklung
unserer DB2-Datenbank.
Analyse von Performanceengpässen
und Ableiten von Optimierungsmöglichkeiten
für Anwendungsentwicklung und IT-Betrieb.
Ausbau des Monitorings im Hinblick auf
Analyse- und Prognosemöglichkeiten des Systems.
Aha.
Ähm.
Und.
Erfahrung mit DB2-Datenbank.
Sicherer Umgang mit IBM ZUS Mainframe.
TSO.
Das, das, das habe ich,
das kenne ich.
Das, das habe ich,
das habe ich schon mal gehört im Mainframe-Umfeld.
RAC oder RACF oder so.
Gibt es irgendwie RACF-IDs und sowas?
Das kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor.
DB2-SQL.
Gute Arbeitsweise geprägt von bla bla bla bla bla.
Übrigens, wir legen von Beginn an Wert
auf eine intensive Einarbeit.
Ja, das ist gut.
Kommt euch ja auch zugute.
Ich finde es immer geil, wenn, wenn das,
ich meine, das ist ja schon von Vorteil, ne,
aber wenn die das so schreiben,
ich finde, das sollte zum eigensten,
zum ureigensten Interesse gehören
eines Unternehmens, die neue Leute einstellen,
dass sie die Leute ordentlich einarbeiten,
weil sonst bekommen sie einfach nicht,
nichts richtig für ihr Geld.
Das Berechtigungsmanagement.
Ja, ja, das ergibt Sinn.
Auch vielfältige Bildungshintergründe.
Wir sind aufgeschlossen gegenüber Talenten,
deren Lebenslauf auf den ersten Blick
nicht hundertprozentig zu den Anforderungen passt.
Das finde ich gut, dass sie das so schreiben.
Ja.
Ich meine, man muss sagen,
super ansprechend finde ich die Stellenanzeigen
jetzt trotzdem nicht.
Also unabhängig davon,
dass ich absolut keinen Bock auf DB2-ZUS hätte,
aber super ansprechend finde ich,
finde ich nicht.
Also, seriously, die, die vier hier,
die sind deutlich zu jung,
um ZUS-Admins zu sein.
Also erstmal in der IT-Abteilung
das Verhältnis ein Kerl auf drei Mädels
ist sehr unrealistisch.
Wenn auch nice, aber unrealistisch.
Ähm, und die sind allesamt viel zu jung,
um DB2-ZUS zu machen.
Mehr Details zu unseren Benefits.
Kulinarik.
Wie sieht's aus?
Wie sieht's mit Homeoffice aus?
Hybrides Arbeiten.
Spiel mal den Film ab.
Man meinte, der ist cringe.
Super agil mit Basketball.
Ey, so typischer böses Enterprise-Film, man.
Naja.
Das war so ein typischer Promotion-Film halt.
Den hätte man eigentlich auch weglassen können, ja.
Aber,
aber,